i think because they play so well on the
defensive end quinn snyder's loses them
up a little bit offensively
lamelo all right great ball for the
rookie
and lamelo ball puts his head down look
at this dribbling in and out
could have been a foul right there gets
to the left hand he's got 12 points
lamelo bottom off the well
and another rip away three on one
biz with the left hand
[Applause]
base stealer stretch a single to a
double
oh beautiful dime and bins catches in
fantastic assist the confidence to
step back and bottom a triple oh
lavello the youngster
answers and then lamelo steps back
shoots it over favors
[Applause]
lamello wrap around pass a beauty
and fizz cashes it in because he went
aggressively to the hole
burst of speed right there and look go
bears
he's getting ready to go try to block
that shot and he goes where'd the ball
go
right around lamelo
gets it back from hayward and with the
left
hand the 19 year old
has figured out the pro game it is
give it go and switch it to the left
it's got magnificent body control yeah
it's got a gorgeous